hello everyone and welcome to the final
round of the Gibraltar 2020 chess
festival it's Maxine bascillica versus
par hammock Sulu and it's it's quite the
game
maxime going into this round half a
point behind mock Zulu some exceed Mach
Zulu is in the lead like we mentioned in
the previous video and after he is a
well miracle game against se panco
now he faces mvl whit whit black so I
would out further ado let's check it out
as they are they are both kind of
fighting fighting still for first place
if Maxine wins he gets the seven and a
half and if max Lewinsky he gets the
eight which kind of gives him chances to
grab so lead so let's let's see what
happens
MVL opens with the d4 we have d5 c4 and
east six the Queens gambit declined is
on the board Knight c3 Bishop to b4 and
now going into the air goes in defense
Knight to f6 we have C captures sorry
that's not a c c captures and e5 e
captures and Bishop to g5 so all all
fairly standard moves with III and
Bishop to f5 and now that you are no
longer regarding the b7 pawn Queen b3
putting pressure on the on the d5 pawn
but also on the b7 pawn after the bishop
moves so Bishop captures on c3 and now
you could capture with a pawn but here
am BL chooses Queen captures on c3
instead and now h6 and this position has
been reached before twice by 11 RN and
played with black against both ding and
the Nakamura being played Bishop to h4
here it was played in Palmer the America
Grand Prix in 2017 that game ended in a
draw and Nakamura
I played the Bishop captures on f6 it
was played also in 2017 in in Norway
chess and that game also ended in a draw
so here instead of Bishop h4 Bishop f6
the max team chooses Bishop to f4 and
did it this is now a new move so already
as of move 10 we have a completely new
game so let's see what happens so
seasick seems like a perfectly
reasonable move you you strengthen your
central you continues to develop pieces
but like we've seen in the previous game
max Lulu doesn't often go for the
normal moves so instead he goes Knight
to e4 attacks the Queen and goes for a
most interesting pawn sacrifice point is
you cannot grab with the bishop due to
let say Queen e7 your queen is still
under attack and after rook attacks
Bishop it's game over
so after Knight to e4 we have Queen
captures on c7 by mvl and now max we'll
just continue developing Knight to c6 so
what happens here could you could you
grab another pawn well not not likely if
you if you go quick after some b7 then
you get Queen to a5 with check and you
run into into a lot of problems here
after the King moves somewhere like the
King to e2 already you don't want your
King I need to look is coming to c8
defending the knight then this row comes
here and it's just a very quick death
for black for white so after Knight c6
we have Bishop to b5 by mvl just
threatening to capture on on c6 and now
rook the c8 forcing this trade again you
cannot capture here due to Queen a5
check so Queen captures on d8 we have
looked FCAT force and e8 and now and
we'll just castles so a lot of
development for that for the price of
one point and now g5 we have Bishop the
g3 and now h5 threatening to win the
bishop here so h3 making some room for
the bishop but now the problem is
maxilla can always capture on g3 and the
double-double White's pawns here and
well we would have messed up on
structure like that perhaps his being
perhaps him being down upon will not be
so relevant so tonight's the e7 first
now opening up the C file he might want
to activate the rook we are rook to c2
so look after c1 of course MBL doesn't
allow it and now Knight captures on g3
we have F captures and g3 and now even
g4 making sure that these pawns stay
stay put like this so H captures H
captures we have Knight back to d2 and
to now Bishop the c2 preventing any any
piece activation from from maxime so
tonight the b1 now preparing night
see three so the Roku no longer be
guarding the bishop
we have gush of Capra zombie one we have
rook captures unbe one and now f5 now
defending the g4 pawn and the making
room for his King to enter the game Bush
back to d3 puts pressure on the f5 pawn
and our king f7 mokuba starts bringing
his King into the game and now rook c3
preparing to double up on the C file
saying that if you capture here I'm
gonna fix my pawn structure here have a
nice semi-open fall for my rook so
instead just King e6 now the F pawn is
nicely defended by the King you can now
move your knight King F 2 and the now
rook the h8 now with ideas of using the
H file if the King is activated then you
can just very easily go after the pawns
here so rook to a3 I'm going after the
a7 point here at mocs we will defend it
you could play a six but Mac Zulu
decides that maybe maybe he wants to
play a 5 at some point we've worked the
c1 now preparing to bring the rook to c7
and now Knight to c8 you could try King
to d6 to prevent it but then rook a to
c3 might might pose some problems and
you will not be able to trade rooks
along the C file because after all is
traded and nothing regards your f5 bond
here so that's that's the issue so here
after rook c1 we have Knight to c8 point
being that if Brooks c7 and ninety six
guards everything the b7 point is
protected the da point is protected so
it's not really not really a problem and
even if you double works now there's
really nowhere to go here so after
Knight to c8 with b4 by Maxine
preventing any expansion by by black and
now comes Knight to d6 the c-4 square is
nicely protected so you don't have to
worry about not coming to see for
Knights the e4 might be an idea at some
point but b5 grabbing even more space
with rook H back to c8 and now rook the
c5 saying that ok if you capture I can
capture back I get a very nice pawn here
I can easily create a passed pawn if I
just push c6 at some point also there
might be ideas of even b6 followed by c6
and then B 7 a lot of things boss
here so look back to d8 as the roof is
also attacking the defy phone you might
have some ideas of maybe going after
that pawn
soft rock the DA to just defendant if
the knight moves with rook 8a c 3 and
now rook to d7 not allowing rook to c7
we have a 4 and now b6 attacking the
rook rook the c6 and now rook B to D 8
so sorry Arouca D to D 8 just going back
we have King to e 2 now trying to
activate the king but now rook to d7 we
worked the c1 and now rook the a treat
again with the idea that the king is not
not allowed any activity the King has to
guard the pawns here we have a 5 by
Maxine now just the threatening to win
the pawn here so be captures an a5 and
now rook the a6 preparing to recapture
with this but also to make another
uplift with rook C to c6 so we have
looked at h2 attacking and now King if
to going back and now look who goes back
as well think ok you are you you stay
here
so rook C to c6 now attacking the knight
here and here
rook H to f7 the defending the pawn here
so we have king - e - and now a for just
pushing the pawn but doesn't really
matter so rook captures an a4 we have
worked the b7 and I'll just rock back to
a6 attacking the knight here and now
rook F to d7
so the the rooks just switched places we
have King to d2 again trying to activate
it in now King g7 unpinning so the
knight can move we have cooked the c5
again going for the pawn and now again
King e6 defending we have king to c3 and
now rook to b8
again with the idea that this rook
should start picking up some points on
the King side
King to be four and now rook to h8 my
Mac Zulu we have worked the c1 with the
idea that a rook to f1 will go after the
f5 points since the night here I spent
the night is not actually
guarding the pawn so rook the h2 and now
comes Luke the f1 by Maxime also a very
strong idea was king to c5 but it
requires a lot of precise calculation
for example if rook captures then you
get rook h1 and now rook to h6 will just
be winning so you have to react to this
rook system in check
now you block and after a captures
captures it's just just a very strong
position for white 294 check captures
captures and now of course black wants
to deliver this check but you're first
gonna go rook h6 check King g7 you're
gonna go Luke h7 check King e6 and now
d5 check and now that you've connected
the points it's it's a winning game but
a lot of things to calculate of course
so Maxime instead goes for rook to f1 he
has a bit of a different plan King East
7 unpinning now the night also guards
the pawn here but doesn't really matter
Bishop captures an f5 and Knight
captures rook captures and rook captures
and g2 rook the g5 are going for rook to
g7 check and here King t8 might might be
the way to go but then you you have to
give up the pawn here so instead maxilla
said ok I'm gonna try and survive this
with rook g3 but now rogue g7 check King
yet and now rook captures on d7 with
king jarasandh e7 and now rook captures
an a7 creating a past beep on kink the
e6 and now b6 so here max Lulu has to do
something about the past beep on he goes
rook to g1 he wants to put the room
behind the past pawn b7 and now look the
be one with check we have King to c5 and
here Mac Zulu really took a deep think
not too deep but you know quite deep and
the problem is there's there's really no
good way to play this for example if you
start a race with the g3 then you get
rook the Asics check King d7 and rook b6
just blocking the pawn and now this will
be will be just well winning for example
capture screen captures and then now
after g2 you're gonna go into this
endgame with with Queens on the board
but with the white having two points to
1 and this pawn
well being fairly easily
guessable you will also win this pawn
and the game so that's one way to do it
the other way is to try King of five so
rookie six doesn't come with the check
but then you just go King c6 and after
g3 rook a8 you're gonna go g2 and now
just a rook the g8 and there is no
problem King before you're just gonna
play rook captures in g2 and there's no
past pawn now were gonna play King c7
Queen the pawn and win the game so
instead Mac Zulu Mac Zulu try something
different
rook the c1 check we have Kingston b6
and now rugby one check King to c7 rook
the c1 check and now kink to d8 bye-bye
maximal Oh King Tubby it was also very
interesting for example now if ruby won
now you go King to a eight and now after
g3 now you go b8 Queen and after real
captures you're gonna go King captures
and now well it's it's very easy to
catch it upon your threatening Ruby g7
so King to f6 has to be played but now
you're just gonna bring your King here
when this point end a roofed a1 always
stops the past bone so it's not a
problem but Maxine goes for King d8
instead we have looked the b1 again
putting the rogue behind the passed pawn
and now rook a6 with check King f5 and
now King back to c7 now we have g3 by
Mac Sulu and here it's a very
interesting position feel free to pause
the video and what what is the best move
here for white while I give you a couple
of seconds so there are two ways to play
this there's the there's the way Maxine
plated and there's a there's a much
cleaner way so Maxine went for rook the
b6 the plan that we discuss that was
possible all along and he went for that
Queen's endgame however kink
sorry instead of rook to b6 b8 Queen
seems to be sufficient and and much much
cleaner for example rook captures King
captures g2 you go rook to a-1 defending
the pawn king to e4 you're gonna go kink
the c7 now and after King captures any
three you're gonna go rook to d1 you
defend this pawn and now black has to
make a choice kingi two attacks the rook
rook to g1
King f2 and then now just rook captures
Angie - that's the point
and after Cain captures King D six King
f3 and now you eliminate the pawn you
move the king and the pawn when Queens
and wins the game
it requires of course a lot of
calculation under a lot of pressure is
the last game of the tournament so Maxie
went for rook the Beast sex it's a sure
thing ever
and you go into the the Queen's endgame
which you already saw on the thumbnail
rook captures an b6 it's a must play
King captures g2 and we get this endgame
that we discussed but through a much
different move order and now I just
Queen to e5 check it's a little bit
better than one we've shown because here
you pick up the pawn instantly so King
g6 with King to c6 now preparing to win
the pawn with the King Quinta a1 now
Queen g3 with check King to f5 and now
Queen to f4 check King g6 and now King
cat person d5 so it's two points again
zero but you have to avoid all the
checks if if possible and of course
mokuba will try anything to grab a draw
maybe some sort of a perpetual maybe
maybe you know force white into a
stalemate a lot of a lot of things are
possible so Queen eight check he starts
with this Queen King c4 Quinta a4 with
check King to c3 went to a one with Jeff
King to d2 we have Queen to be to with
check and King the e1 now Queen to g2
now asking white what do you want to do
here and now Queen to f1 are just
preventing preventing any useful checks
so we have Queen back to C - and now
Queen to f3
maxime wants to have the absolute
perfect setup before he starts pushing
his pawns here we have King to g7 and
now King f1 we have Queen to see one
check King to g2 and now Queen to c2
with check King to g3 and Queen to c7
with check with King to h3 and now this
is what Maxime wanted and the for those
of you who are perhaps new to chess
might might find it interesting how to
how to convert this endgame but even if
you're if you're an experienced player
doesn't really matter
how much you've studied a queen and
ponen game you will always always play
suboptimal moves alright it's just the
way it is so here of course you cannot
deliver check if you check then Queen
checks forces a queen trade and then of
course King and pawn and game will be
winning so you have to do something else
Queen c3 okay you cannot advance the
pawn because the Queen hangs but you can
advance the D pawn so queen d3 now
hoping for some queen h7 action but King
g3 again you cannot to deliver check
because this force is a queen trade King
g6 now Queen g4 check King h7 now Queen
to d7 check King h8 we have Quinta EA to
check King to g7 Queen East 7 check King
to h8 and now Queen e5 check we have
King to h7 and here it's interesting Mac
Zulu is down to one minute on the clock
so he really has to decide quickly where
to go with his King and now d6 finally
so again you have to go through a series
of checks Queen g6 check King gauge for
and now again check is impossible due to
due to just blocking so Queen the b1
hoping to again get some checks from
behind Queen c7 check with King to g6
now Queen e6 check King to h7 and now d7
so what both bones are nicely guarded by
the Queen Black has to have to try
something Queen e1 check we have King
the g5 but now it's fairly fairly
obvious where the king is going King g3
we have King f6 Queen h4 checking of 7
now Queen h5 check and finally King to
f8 and here if you deliver this check
then again Queen blocks and forces a
Queen trade if you deliver this track
again Queenie 7 blocks and delivers
check so forces the Queen trade so here
Mac Zulu played Queen to a5 but now
Queen east 7 check just guarding the
queening Square King juice ex and now d8
Queen so of course a maxime had to check
if there were any sneaky checks here to
the kind of forces stalemate but but
there aren't with the king being so far
away from the corner so here quinta f5
check was played King to g8 and here as
this is only moved 99 instead of
resigning Matsu blue played one more
move he gave up his Queen I guess just
to make it 100
moves or maybe it was sort of a bluff
maybe to force the King into moving and
then maybe sacrificing the Queen
it's interesting the here of course
Maxime captured and it was in this
position that Parma resigned the game
and move 100 but maybe maybe it was sort
of a a bluff maybe maybe if King 2h8 if
there was maybe a a possibility to
create some sort of a stalemate but it
doesn't doesn't appear so for ya not
likely maybe if something like King to
h6 and then Queen captures here but
still you have the g6 square so it's
very unlikely so I still think it was
just to reach move 100 I don't think he
tried anything else here but yeah
maxilla stays on seven points and but
seem a propels with his one full point
in the it would win in the final round
to 7 and a half and now 7 people are
tied for first place and they are going
in two tiebreaks which I will also cover
there they're playing them as we as we
well as I'm making this video so we'll
see what happens then are they a really
really impressive stuff very active game
from Oxford as you're used to you know
max Ubu is always doing crazy stuff and
his games are always very interesting
but yeah they don't always work out
against 2770 player like Maxime for
Sheila graph but yeah I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank the lee
young-shin IVA Fresa and the Michael
Sklar for contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the growth our chess masters
well the tiebreaks of course and then we
are heading to the Palmer V saga thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day